bonsoir et bienvenue pour une édition
spéciale du 7 8 noël approche la
rédaction va vous proposer dans un
instant ces conseils pour passer un bon
réveillon avant de vous présenter à nos
invités qui sont déjà sur ce plateau
voici quelques-uns des sujets qui seront
à découvrir ce soir les fêtes de Noël
approchent pour les magasins c'est le
rush toute une logistique à mettre en
place vous découvrirez cela du côté de
Maurepas
vous n'avez peut-être pas encore terminé
votre sapin de Noël et vous cherchez une
idée originale une société de Manille et
hameaux mise sur le sapin recyclable
sujet également à suivre ce soir depuis
ce mercredi jusqu'au 23 décembre le
théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines reçoit une
troupe de cirque pour vous plonger dans
l'univers de Tim Burton une
représentation unique en Île-de-France
et puis la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet accueille une crèche vivante
les animaux de la ferme mis en scène
l'occasion aussi de découvrir les
agneaux nouveau-nés et après ce point
sur les titres il est temps de recevoir
nos premiers invités 7 8 spéciales Noël
une heure d'émission en direct si vous
nous suivez à 18h en ce 19 décembre
qu'as-tu commandé à Noël
une trottinette
des Playmobil
les peluches
des Monster High
après
des PetShop
des bleus
des Playmobil des Lego
et vous vous avez commandé quoi
j'ai commandé
un baudrier pour l'escalade du matériel
d'escalade et puis des brasser
un jeu de PS3 des habits et un casque
et bienvenue sur ce plateau du 7 8 de
tvfils 78 redécoré aux couleurs de Noël
bonsoir Johanna une heure d'édition
spéciale pour célébrer Noël édition
spéciale vous avez passé votre commande
aussi au Père Noël
pas encore j'ai pas eu le temps on
travaille trop on n'a pas le temps d'y
penser il va falloir s'y mettre
avec nous ce soir nous allons recevoir
plusieurs invités le chocolatier Franck
De Beauce le secrétaire général du
Secours populaire des Yvelines Pascal
Rodier ou encore Pauline de Breteuil la
nouvelle directrice du château de
Choisel mais tout de suite nous avons
des invités qui sont autour de cette
table marine poubelle bonsoir vous êtes
référente jeune public au cinéma Les
Yeux d'Elsa à Saint-Cyr-l'École Valérie
Ferré bonsoir la directrice de l'office
de tourisme de Saint-Quentin et Joël
Alessandra illustrateur également
bonsoir donc à vous trois au programme
pour les prochaines 20 minutes cinéma et
puis quelques bons plans bien sûr pour
vous sortir en cette période de fin
d'année Marilyn alors vous avez organisé
une journée ciné compte autour de Noël
au cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa
Saint-Cyr-l'École c'est une réelle
volonté ça du cinéma d'organiser des
événements particuliers au cours des
saisons de l'actualité oui on essaie de
faire des événements à peu près tous les
deux mois pour le jeune public avec des
ateliers alors là c'est un petit peu
spécial parce que c'est Noël donc depuis
quelques années on fait un ciné compte
avec Bertie soulier qui est une conteuse
qu'on aime beaucoup donc elle vient
accompagner des films d'animation donc
là elle les a introduit donc avant
chaque court métrage Bertille racontait
des histoires donc à sa façon très
rythmée pétillante pour colorer un petit
peu déjà l'univers russe de tous ses
courts-métrages alors nous étions nous
avons assisté à ce ciné compte si vous
le voulez bien nous allons justement
vous rapporter quelques images
à quelques jours de Noël le cinéma Les
Yeux d'Elsa a souhaité mettre en lumière
des histoires de Russie ponctuées par
l'intervention d'une conteuse Bertie
soulier les enfants de Saint-Cyr-l'École
ont pu découvrir le concept du
cinécompte là ici c'est très particulier
parce que c'est plusieurs petits
courts-métrages et j'interviens à
l'intérieur des petits courts métrages
et le but du jeu voilà c'est
d'introduire de préparer les enfants au
court-métrage comme une mise en bouche
c'était contre eux seulement qui a un
rossignol qui est mis en scène il y a
une cabane extraordinaire à la cabane de
Biquette qui est entièrement construite
avec des gâteaux
sucrés salés
des images délicieuses et des messages
de liberté pour ce signe et compte
unique au mois de décembre le reste de
la programmation du cinéma de
Saint-Cyr-l'École est à retrouver sur
internet
est-ce que ceci n'est compte a eu un
vrai succès le public effrayant les
jeunes sont friands
plus de 150 personnes donc on est on est
plutôt content oui Noël forcément c'est
associé au cinéma c'est un moment pour
se retrouver aussi en famille oui oui on
espère en tout cas je rappelle que le
cinéma est ouvert donc pendant les fêtes
donc après Noël il y a plusieurs
programmes pour les familles il y a
notamment
Ernest et Célestine je pense que les
parents en ont entendu parler parce que
c'est un très très bon film que je
recommande il y a aussi les bêtes du Sud
sauvage qui a eu des critiques
dithyrambiques donc c'est aussi un film
familial n'hésitez pas à venir le voir
il y a les cinq légendes le Hobbit aussi
le Hobbit qui est assez attendu et puis
et pour les plus grands je mélange tous
les tous les âges et puis pour les plus
petits gens de la lune votre coup de
cœur cinéma c'est vraiment Ernest et
Célestine comme vous vous le ferry
qui a été sélectionné à la Quinzaine des
Réalisateurs au Festival de Cannes en
2012 et qu'on vous conseil si vous avez
des enfants en bas âge je vous organisez
aussi des rendez-vous avec les
réalisateurs et notamment le prochain
rendez-vous ça sera un ciné goûter animé
début février les mercredises et samedi
9 février à 14h alors en quoi ça
consiste alors ça c'est donc dans les
prochaines événements jeunes publiques
là ça va être un peu particulier donc il
y a pas de d'inviter mais on va donc
organiser animé un atelier après les
films sachant que c'est un programme
autour de comment filmer le réel alors
ça paraît un petit peu sérieux comme ça
mais vous inquiétez pas c'est c'est
quand même plein d'imagination enfin
c'est le but de ce programme de montrer
que que le Cinéma du Réel est aussi
plein d'imagination et après on aimerait
faire un atelier donc déjà pour discuter
avec le jeune public c'est à partir de 7
ans et l'idée c'est que chacun ramène un
petit objet auquel il tient et je n'en
dis pas plus pas plus je laisse le
mystère sur cet atelier ce qu'on fera on
va évidemment essayer de faire des
images d'accord donc ça c'est début
février puis ensuite le 12 février à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des enfants soldats il y aura un ciné
débat
réalisé également partenariat avec
Amnesty International cette fois-ci oui
alors là c'est après le film rebelle
donc un film canadien c'est un
documentaire alors non c'est une fiction
d'accord puisque ça se passe dans un
pays imaginaire en Afrique mais le pays
n'est pas n'existe pas et c'est un
mélange de témoignages sur la durée
réalité donc de la condition des enfants
soldats et en même temps des échappés
oniriques et je voudrais juste signaler
que la l'actrice a eu le prix à Berlin
le prix d'interprétation et donc voilà
pareil les critiques sont vraiment très
élogieuses et je vous invite donc à
venir à ce débat après le film avec
Amnesty c'est un film plutôt pour les
adultes ou les enfants s'ils peuvent
imaginons plutôt après 12 ans alors en
février il y aura également d'autres
films à cheval aussi sur le mois de
janvier dont The weekndbi de Michel
Gondry j'ai noté du 16 janvier au 5
février ça c'est un film que j'ai
beaucoup aimé je sais pas si vous l'avez
vu
pas encore très bon film on ne demandez
pas moi mais moi oui
moi aussi c'est un film vraiment que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup adoré et qu'on
n'a pas encore pu montrer donc là c'est
l'occasion de le montrer et en fait on
avait vraiment envie qu'il ait une vraie
existence donc on le garde sur plusieurs
semaines pour voilà parce que il y a
tellement de filles ça se ça se voilà ça
se bouscule un petit peu et là l'idée
c'est de le montrer de le proposer enfin
parce qu'on a un peu on a plus de place
et de le garder sur plusieurs semaines
la même chose avec les Hurlevent
d'Andréa Arnold et puis rebelle aussi
qu'on va garder et puis le film aussi
rengaine qui est un petit film je sais
pas si vous avez entendu parler le
réalisateur a mis plus de 6 ans à le
faire autoproduit etc donc voilà l'idée
c'est d'essayer de garder des films sur
la durée pour voilà faire venir du monde
et puis qu'il y ait plus de qui est plus
de séances et de possibilités et puis
les faire exister un petit peu plus
ou à Versailles il est originaire de
Versailles c'est l'occasion en plus de
le souligner on reste dans l'univers du
cinéma mais du cirque également Johanna
vous étiez où hier curieux et oui mais
j'étais au théâtre de 50 ans en Yvelines
pour voir un spectacle magnifique qui
s'appelle whereyround c'est du cirque
contemporain qui nous vient tout droit
de Suède nous avons rencontré les
artistes qui font partie de la troupe si
le coup silkel enfin j'ai pris des cours
de surveilles si vous aimez Tim Burton
vous allez adorer
sur scène ils sont 6 6 artistes venus de
Scandinavie membre de la compagnie
circuser si vous aimez les arts du
cirque et le fantastique le spectacle
wherekround vous séduira ouibuster
sweet charders
leur esthétique ressemble à celle de Tim
Burton elle plonge le spectateur dans
une dimension absurde aux couleurs noir
et blanc
la compagnie suédoise de cirque
contemporain vous invite à découvrir son
univers onirique au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin tous les jours jusqu'au
dimanche 23 décembre
c'est un très beau cadeau de Noël alors
j'ai justement parlant de cadeaux un
autre un autre support c'est un livre
les 50 années d'une en balade alors pour
en parler avec nous les auteurs nous ont
rejoint donc Valérie Ferrer vous êtes
directrice de l'office de tourisme de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à vos côtés
Joël Alessandra c'est vous qui avez
dessiné le livre vous êtes
l'illustrateur vous avez aussi pensé
alors comment vous est venu l'idée
comment vous avez travaillé ensemble
alors l'idée déjà de l'ouvrage
50 ans en Yvelines ayant un office de
tourisme on se devait et on avait envie
à l'office de promouvoir le territoire
de le faire découvrir à l'ensemble des
personnes habitant sur 50 ans mais aussi
des visiteurs occasionnels on voulait
que ce soit un ouvrage qui s'adresse à
une large population aussi bien des
adultes que des adolescents des enfants
et on voulait que ce soit ludique
agréable joyeux convivial et que ça
retrace voilà que ce soit l'image de
Saint-Quentin qu'il y ait aussi bien de
l'art que du contenu qu'on sache un
petit peu de quoi on parle pourquoi tel
événement comment il a été conçu etc
donc c'était un projet assez ambitieux
dans son contenu en tous les cas et en
fait l'idée du de l'aquarelle de
l'agenda elle est venue tout simplement
lors d'une balade dans une librairie en
voyant un ouvrage qui existait un peu
comme enfin pas comme celui-là un petit
peu sous forme d'agenda avec des
aquarelles sur Paris mais version très
romantique parisienne et beaucoup plus
agenda avec possibilité d'écrire dessus
voilà et puis c'est ça mûri ça mûri avec
l'équipe de l'Office de Tourisme on a on
a voulu vraiment créer quelque chose de
différent qui qui répondent à des
attentes parce que effectivement les
gens quand ils viennent à 50 ans il nous
demande qu'y a-t-il à faire tout de
suite maintenant à Saint-Quentin donc il
fallait qu'on ordonne l'offre possible
sur Saint-Quentin moi par mois c'est
aussi pour ça que que l'agenda c'était
une bonne idée parce que on pouvait
répondre aussi directement au public et
ça nous servait à nous comme support
comme outil de travail une espèce
d'agenda alors c'est pas un réel agenda
parce qu'il y a pas de de date précise
mais c'est par mois voilà les choses
qu'on peut faire sur 50 ans en Yvelines
par exemple en août que fait-on en août
à 50 ans
les beaux jours réchauffons-nous un peu
les beaux jours en outre que fait pour
nous
la poterie dans le gardien
et voilà
vous êtes
rencontré alors on s'est rencontré parce
qu'un ami commun qui
qui travaille dans la communication et
moi quand je lui ai parlé du projet il
m'a dit peut-être que éventuellement
cette agence de communication qui
s'appelle l'agence illumination pourrait
répondre à ta demande donc on a fait un
cahier des charges on a fait un appel
d'offres et puis deux agences ont
répondu donc l'agence illumination de
Joël Alessandra et une autre agence de
Versailles mais qui n'était plus dans
les temps et qui de toute façon ne
répondait pas nous proposer un produit
complètement différent enfin des jeux
c'était pas tout à fait adapté à la à
l'offre donc choix des monuments et
c'est vous qui l'avez qu'il avait fait
sur quels critères vous vous êtes fondés
alors en fait il y a plusieurs critères
alors juste pour pour dire enfin moi
j'ai plusieurs casquettes j'ai la
casquette illumination donc je suis
directeur de création de l'agence de
communication mais je suis aussi auteur
de bande dessinée car il voyage donc ça
correspondait tout à fait aux besoins de
l'Office de Tourisme puisque on avait
justement plusieurs regards dans dans le
bouquin qu'on a fait
plusieurs entrées donc une entrée de
communication et d'information et puis
une entrée un petit peu plus gérer plus
lyrique plus balade comme comme on
l'entend c'est-à-dire vraiment avec des
des dessins d'aquarelle très
très promenade anglaise en fait je dis
anglaise parce que les anglais sont très
forts pour les aquarelles de landscape
etc et pourquoi je dis ça parce que
il y a au niveau voilà
très très belle expérience parce que
donc n'étant pas de de 50 ans en
Yvelines j'avais aussi un regard un
petit peu candide sur sur les sur tout
ce dont on pouvait parler dans dans cet
agenda que ce soit au niveau des
événements qu'au niveau
ah oui alors ça nous a fait du bien
à nous est-ce que
vous preniez
et en fait on a présenté des documents à
Joël notamment la carte du patrimoine
qui recense tous les sites et les et les
les oeuvres d'art sur Saint-Quentin et
on a décidé de faire un une sélection de
ses œuvres de façon à pouvoir les faire
apparaître dans l'agenda
en fait là je peux vous dire qu'au mois
de novembre il y a signé 3D c'est pas
possible avec un rhinocéros
effectivement chaque mois de l'année est
illustré et on peut piocher comme ça en
fonction de la période de l'année
société que ce soit transversal
c'est-à-dire que toutes les thématiques
soient présentes que toutes les communes
bien sûr soient présentes on a même
débordé de 50 ans en Yvelines puisqu'on
est allés jusqu'à Thoiry et le PNR d'une
façon générale à travers la fête des
femmes parce que ça participe de
l'attractivité de 50 ans en Yvelines
aussi c'est là on a pas parlé du château
de Versailles ils ont pas besoin de ça
et nous non plus d'ailleurs et puis et
puis comme le disait Joël effectivement
les différentes entrées ça permet
effectivement avec notamment les petits
les petits personnages de s'adresser
peut-être à un public plus jeune de
dynamiser un peu le propos et cet agenda
ce guide on peut le retrouver à l'Office
de Tourisme là où elle est en vente et
en ce moment vous avez aussi une expo de
Noël alors pas que l'office de tourisme
dans les librairies au pavé du canal
juste savoir ce que vous avez retenu que
ce qui vous a marqué à 50 ans en
Yvelines vous qui avez découvert le
territoire
exposition de Noël donc puisque c'est
forcément la période une autre idée de
Noël c'est le nom de l'expédition
pourquoi une autre idée de Noël parce
que
parce qu'on voulait un univers un peu
alors on était très ambitieux au départ
on voulait un univers très 3D très
hologramme et compte tenu de des prix on
pouvait pas se permettre d'arriver à
on pouvait pas se permettre d'arriver
voilà la hauteur de nos ambitions donc
on est resté sur un univers avec des
voilà beaucoup de lumière des aurores
boréales des lumières noires qui mettent
en valeur des des couleurs
phosphorescentes
il y a des ateliers voilà des ateliers
avec aussi la possibilité sur un très
très grand écran de faire de la Wii de
lancer des boules de neige de faire du
surf etc enfin des neiges voilà donc
c'est c'est plutôt un public de groupes
scolaire notamment qui viennent très
nombreux mais bien sûr toutes les
familles il y a des poufs il y a un coin
compte beaucoup de gens viennent se
relaxer entre midi et deux aussi voilà
de fin d'année une autre idée de Noël à
l'Office de Tourisme de 50 ans en
Yvelines Montigny-le-Bretonneux à
découvrir cet ouvrage on en a parlé 51
en Yvelines en balade voilà vous l'avez
aperçu tout à l'heure vos différents
ouvrages aussi vous les avez glissés
pendant l'entretien on les a vu de
manière subliminal
retour du Tchad Kennedy j'en ai plein
d'autres
cadeaux pour cette période de fin
d'année et n'oubliez pas également le
cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa Saint-Cyr-l'École
et sa programmation toujours très riche
merci donc à tous les trois d'être venu
sur le plateau le 7 8 édition spéciale
Noël va se poursuivre deux journalistes
de la rédaction vont nous rejoindre
Anthony Rey chez Valérie Auribeau nous
parlerons solidarité et puis je de Noël
également pour l'instant quelques idées
cadeaux de Noël à d'autres idées les
tendances du moment si vous manquez
encore d'idées et dépêchez-vous il vous
reste très peu de temps
si vous êtes en panne d'inspiration pour
vos cadeaux cette année les jeux en bois
et les jeux mécaniques restent une
valeur sûre à tirer et puis des grands
classiques comme comme des puzzles les
jeux de construction etc il y a pas
forcément de de grosses nouveautés cette
année dans ce magasin de Maurepas depuis
quelques jours les parents s'occupent
déjà de la liste de leurs enfants et
malgré la crise il continue de remplir
la haute du Père Noël pour le 25
décembre en fait les autres auront pas
de cadeaux mais mes enfants auront des
cadeaux c'est tout faire les autres ils
auront moins de cadeaux quoi
aux alentours de 70 euros par enfant il
n'y aura pas forcément de nouveautés
cette année sous le sapin mais le cadeau
très tendance c'est la tablette tactile
le contenu est adapté aux enfants vous
avez à l'intérieur du contenu Ludo
éducatif vous allez avoir des activités
pour les enfants qui sont en rapport
avec la vie de tous les jours pour
apprendre des petites recettes de
cuisine des jeux de récréation des
petits cours de bricolage à côté du
cadeau technologies chez les filles la
mode est au vampire et au petit monstres
à côté des classiques poupées des
costumes de princesses
chez les garçons les éternels jeux de
construction restent dans le top des
ventes mais les toupies devraient être
encore nombreuses sur les listes un
produit populaire qui est déjà en
rupture de stock
c'est sur ce fauteuil que le Père Noël
accueillera les enfants tout le mois de
décembre une période pendant laquelle
les spécialistes du jouet réalisent 50%
de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel